what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation uh we got ourselves a
trailer from the game awards Suicide
Squad kills the Justice League it's the
official Batman reveal and this is
supposed to be Kevin Conroy's last time
voicing the Batman
um I mean we've said it a couple of live
streams we never did a dedicated video
just exclusively about Kevin Conroy but
I'm glad we get to get one last gift
from the guy
so let's see what this trailer is all
about
if you can leave a like that would be
very much appreciated
there
[Music]
Arkham as the Arkham theme right keep
your eyes
[Music]
yeah we must barricade it
you stay here pal
oh one down
see this
I spent a lot of time dreaming up how I
was gonna kill you with it
your mind now and you're in for a world
of crap
[Music]
oh my god oh golly oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh oh hi guys oh we were just having a
life
you hear that
oh you know what it is
Bruce
still using Shadows to scare the crap
out as criminals huh
don't sweat it Batman doesn't kill
people
oh
damn
damn purple eyes
I am Vengeance I am the Knight
I am Batman
oh [ __ ] Goosebumps oh thank you Kevin
wow gets to give us a very dark
interpretation of Batman here yeah
purple eyes
what's going on in this game The
Brainiac possession or Superman's gone
evil too yeah I have someone powerful
enough to
anyway I'll figure it out later before I
whatever I eventually play this game
um interesting what version of Batman is
this
I know you haven't played the games but
there's a slight spoiler here
it's supposed to be I haven't played
Gotham Knights he's supposed to be dead
after Hurricane so
um is he so he's been reanimated
yes he may is he in a reanimated version
is this his confirmation that he just
faked his own death I I don't know I I
mean he did look kind of gross and veiny
really interesting a little bit
um yeah yeah icky black varicose right
yeah yeah I didn't even notice I was so
focused on the eyes maybe somebody maybe
got red hooded well Harley also said his
name Bruce so who makes sense if it
lines up with Arkham Knight
um
not sure and they played the music too
could just be in tribute to
I don't know I don't know uh it's all
part of the plan it's interconnected
James Gunn is already at work gotta
connect them all that's right
yeah yeah
I don't know this is uh this is the last
one we're covering today and I've been
kind of avoidant of it
um I mean the game's been taking forever
to release
this forever it's been taking such a
long time uh but this just gave it a
dose of something being extra special
especially to hear those those classic
lines at the very end
um but of course delivered with a much
more of a menace and it's cool to be
getting Batman on the flip perspective
here because uh to see Batman through
the perspective of the villains where
the villains don't really view
themselves as the villains and they're
viewing Batman as the villain I think is
a really cool way to see it you know and
I think
Kevin Conroe has done a lot of different
shades of Batman and different like not
every Batman he's played is is like the
same one from the Animated Series right
uh and I mean even in like the live
action version of crisis on infinite
Earths he played a much much darker
borderline deranged it's gonna put it
lightly for Batman
with that Batman that Bruce Wayne was
hasn't been pushed over the edge he was
definitely not uh the one of of a
vigilante spirit that we know and love
of Batman in that one so I'm excited to
hear this and I'm just glad we get one
last go at uh Kevin Conroy getting to
give us a a Batman interpretation I
wonder if it must be recorded for this
but because I can't be just reused I
wouldn't think so uh manipulated I don't
think they would do that I'd be messed
up I don't know because I mean this
trailer certainly gives you the sense
that you know Batman will figure
prominently into the game which I would
imagine I don't know I mean there's all
kinds of voice manipulation Ai and I'm
sure you could Cobble together like a
storyline out of that but I gotta
believe that he would have recorded for
this then that would have been some kind
of dedicated plot line that they're
going with yeah you know like especially
I don't know as soon as what kills the
Justice League I feel like you have to
have a prominence in Batman
just as you would have to have a
prominence of all the rest of them
I mean what would you think I like the
tone of the trailer a lot I like the the
mood of it it feels really it feels
really Macabre I love it it feels messed
up like this this is the suicide squad
yeah I like it because it feels like a
horror game
um I mean none of all the trailers have
always been kind of like pulpey and
exciting and fun yeah and then this to
step into the realm of like Batman's
Aura yeah well that's the thing is that
was what caught me about this trailer
was I at first I was like thinking it
was a sequel just because uh it's
different tonally than what I remember
about the previous you know spots and
trailers I've seen even though those are
still in this wheelhouse of like there's
a bit of humor and there's the edginess
he accidentally slices off a finger like
I I like this because it was so
cinematic and it at least hinted to me
that you know like the game is gonna be
you know pretty exciting I would imagine
pretty intense for what kind of game it
is but something like this also does
make it feel more like a survival horror
especially when you are sort of like in
their perspective and it's just a cut
scene and you're like looking up at this
you know wreckage in the you know upper
levels of this uh facility that they're
in and seeing the guy's body hit the
ground like it is
I feel like you know we've we've talked
about this before in different
iterations about the idea of seeing
Batman purely from the villain's
perspective and having the horror
elements enhanced due to that and uh I I
love that yeah and this is in a way the
most appealing and most exciting trailer
for this game I've seen thus far like
this one
grabbed me in a way I wasn't expecting
the other one's grabbed me in a way I
might have expected whereas this was
like oh wow and then to have the extra
layer of yeah this is Kevin Conroy's
ostensibly final you know Batman voice
performance this was just odd to be in a
game called Suicide Squad kills the
Justice League
but uh you know just the same I mean
it'll be great work either way you know
I agree yeah I agree
yeah I mean I can't find any information
on exactly which Batman is supposed to
be because
she calls him Bruce
so I assume it would be the Arkham
Knight one
um they threw him in the line he
obviously like he obviously faked his
death but I haven't played Gotham Knight
so I I don't know if they like confirm
that or not uh but I mean obviously
faked
but the way it goes down there's no way
Batman would yeah
I'm trying to at least avoid some
details for Adriana thank you it's the
next game I'm gonna complete
um yeah you got to play two more before
that nah I like to watch every movie
from act three yeah
that's how I get my stuff done
all right well
yeah all right well
what did you all think
leave your thoughts down below
um Kevin Conroy rest in peace what was
your favorite performance that he's done
of Batman if you're able to name it
there's a lot to choose from
all right guys well subscribe leave a
like click that Bell and uh let's end
this with a patron of the day shout out
Daniel Gallagher
wanted to say hello to you happy holiday
season I feel like you know this is a
Batman related trailer if anybody at the
patreon this holiday season this is
gonna be great because it's gonna have
nothing to do with him being Scottish
you're gonna love this I feel like
Daniel Gallagher would be the perfect
person to be a prodigy of Bruce Wayne
like I don't know you've got that kind
of you know I see your profile pic and
you look like an affluent cat but you
also look like you maybe have a dark
side so I figure like you would be the
perfect uh you know addition to the bat
family of the reject nation and uh and
this shout out in and of itself is a
gift to you because you love this
especially this particular kind of humor
that I like to throw at you
um but yeah hope you're doing well hope
you're staying well
at apropos of nothing to do with your
job helping people through medicine I
hope you're staying well and feeling
good and thank you for sticking with us
for so long because you know we've
gotten to this point of like man we've
shouted you out like a billion trillion
times that's really cool that we can say
that because you know you've been around
for so long you are like you know a
fixture and I appreciate
your generosity
so be well dude
and uh hey
it's quite a journey Scotland it's quite
a journey yeah
process
[Music]